good morning we're taking a live look of  police investigating a crash between an  suv and someone on a bicycle  as we zoom in with this picture our  photographer chad graves there on the  scene  showing us what's happening we have a  tow truck here removing this small  vehicle  this is the westbound side of tropicana  right after decatur so since the tow  truck is there looks like they should  remove this soon so let's go to the maps  to give you the detour while this is  still there if you want to keep going  westbound you can take either harmon to  the north  or go through ha siena instead because  again westbound tropicana is closed  right after decatur